in its conclusions the council sets out
a series of initiatives to reduce waste
and losses in the future these measures
include the improvement of monitoring
and data collection to better understand
the problem enhancing the use of biomass
in future EU legislation and to
facilitate the donation of unsold food
products to charities we adopted Council
conclusions on two evaluations by the
Commission and had an exchange of views
on the future of EU forest policy the
debate in the council confirms that the
issues related to forests are highly
relevant and that extra EU actions need
to be taken and need to be further
discussed these Council conclusions mark
an important step forward in the fight
against deforestation and illegal timber
on the Commissioner Olivia already
implementing an action plan to support
effort efforts to reduce food waste in
the near future will propose a
harmonized methodology to measure food
waste this will be crucial to actually
monitor our efforts and defiant
effective food food based prevention
strategies in the autumn I will launch a
platform on food waste which will gather
all interested parties with the aim of
sharing with practices and evaluation of
progress made over time within a system
of integrated pest management we want to
favor prevention non-chemical methods
biological controls and low-risk
products whenever as this is possible so
it is important that all stakeholders
make an effort to increase the
availability of sustainable alternatives
the Commission had made an ambitious
proposal answer conditions of use of
glyphosate in particular they have
recommended that follow them to the
Member States a band of a conformal and
called tallava mean from glyphosate
based products to minimize the use in
public parks public play grounds and
gardens and to minimize a pre-harvest
use of glyphosate let me stress my huge
surprise to see that member state could
not adopt these measures of Health
Protection yesterday